[Music]
also very anti-choice he thinks abortion
is murder which first of all don't knock
it till you try it
hey when you do try it really knock it
you know you're gonna get that baby out
of there the White House Correspondents
Dinner this Saturday probably the worst
crime against comedy since The Hangover
Part two but it's not the only unfunny
thing that happened this month marks by
the way the one year anniversary of
Kathy Griffin remember her the single
most unhappy person in America posing
with a severed head of Donald Trump well
today she would on the view of course
and revoked her apology assuming that's
possible for that and then took
additional shots here's part of what she
said it was I can't believe it's been a
year this month that picture was
released right and we already do it's
been yeah take the apology back Don jr.
an error occurs I called him Eddie
Munster and date rape she's a lot of fun
author and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight
so what are we look at you you have this
remarkable ability to stand back and
sort of see the big picture here what
are we looking at in these two
appearances I think actually we are
looking at the death of comedy did you
go to that abortion joke first of all
actually ed Henry insofar as it is a
joke
Edie actually told it better than the
so-called comedian did it relies on a a
sort of word inversion don't try it till
you knock it but if you do try it knock
it out is that a joke that a
professional joke writer should write I
mean what's fascinating to me is is it's
offensive with that I'd quite like a lot
of sharp-edged e so-called dangerous
comedy but this stuff is offensive
without actually being funny if you look
at what she was doing on Saturday night
Kellyanne Conway is a liar
and then Sarah Huckabee Sanders is also
a liar and if she'd had time for
so-called jokes about mattis and Pompeyo
and sessions and the rest of the cabinet
they'd have all been liars - and I
what's sad is that this is such defanged
comedy you were talking about the
cameras and a couple of minutes ago I'd
love to have jokes about the caravans
jokes about North Korea jokes about
president Mac fall this is a smart
sophisticated Washington crowd in black
tie and they're listening to this woman
using the f-word making a joke about how
her private parts require a lot more
yarn than those pink hats on the Trump
parade this is sophisticated wit for the
smartest people in Washington this is
the death of comedy because there's
nothing that the left can make honest
jokes about except to mock Republicans
as liars or are uptight Christian
fundamentalists hung up on abortion
nothing else is left well I mean it was
funny in the same way that the New York
Times op-ed page is funny if by funny
you mean you know within the very narrow
boundaries of what's acceptable that's
that's the movie you can't be funny if
you can't say things no but that's
actually the New York Times op-ed page
is a very is a very good example I could
never get over that when I first came to
this country there'd be four pieces on
there there'd be three dull turgid
earnest pieces about the Bosnian war or
whatever was going on at the time and
then in the corner there'd be some Tweel
ittle mini making coy so-called humorous
jokes about barcode scanners if you're
gonna be a political comedian if this is
the funniest night of the year in
political comedy it requires you
actually to make savage political comedy
not about Sarah Huckabee Sanders makeup
but about serious things like North
Korea and Iran and all the rest of it
it's so in that they I mean what's so
absurd about this stupid hideous
dedication is that are you book people
who can't do anything but say the F word
and yet it's given the status of a sort
of semi state occasion that the
president is somehow rejecting centuries
of tradition if he doesn't show up for
well which is it is it a night of
serious sharp political comedy or is it
just frankly dull turgid people mouthing
off well that's right and totally
unwilling to slay a single sacred cow if
you're brave I don't know make a joke
about something that'll offend people
you live near they would never
absolutely Mark Steyn thank you great to
see you thanks a lot Tucker